hello my friends it's cold outside
nobody told me that was gonna be a thing
right now it is negative 40 in
Minneapolis so it's only negative 2 here
which is good because in the u.s.
negative 2 is like 30 which is balmy
it's quite nice my name is Scott
Hanselman you can go out there in Google
with Bing for Scott and learn all about
me I have absolutely no idea what I'm
doing I did bring way more hardware than
I should have and I didn't warn the
people here
I usually figured I would show up with
one laptop and then I brought a laptop
and another laptop and then two other
computers and three other computers so I
was originally gonna do like this all
slides thing because somebody told me
when you do a keynote it has to be all
slides with evocative stock photography
so I don't want to do any of that
instead I'm gonna do a bunch of demos
with daily builds of software where I
did a get pull while walking here okay
so lower your expectations I think if we
just want to agree as a group that if it
compiles that that's a success of its
own right so I don't want to hear any of
these tweets these passive-aggressive
well I guess the demo gods didn't bless
Scott today if it compiled I think we
can all just pat me on the back and say
great job Scott okay even if it compiles
with warnings right because sometimes
I've seen people like well compile with
warnings but that whole you know var
should be an explicit declaration that
you know that's a little iffy I have a
podcast this is the the advertising
portion of the show does anyone who
knows who I am or followed me online
just this moment as I said I have a
podcast learn that I have a podcast a
couple people okay awesome this is great
I have a podcast to talk to you sir I
have done 675 episodes of this podcast
over 13 years every single Thursday in
fact episode
666 I talked to someone who analyzed the
source code of doom and wrote a book
about it took me six hundreds it took me
the the podcast of the beast in order to
actually make that happen I waited and
held on to that podcast for many many
years I would encourage you to check it
out it's got a lot of fresh faces
it's called Hansel minutes because I'm a
really bad estimator people say how many
minutes will that take about 30 minutes
and they'll go is that Hansel minutes or
actual minutes which is a really mean
way of saying that a handfull minute is
about an hour I do work at the Microsoft
and on the forest moon of Endor but I
work in open source which is great and
since there's no Darth Vader anymore
it's just basically a bunch of
stormtroopers trying not to blow up
another planet you know of course I went
there to do open source and people said
I was a sellout and that hurt my
feelings but I've worked through it
I've found a way in myself and totally
internally to understand that it's okay
to work at Microsoft this is me before
Microsoft I'm the one on the left there
and then this is me after Microsoft it's
been a lovely lovely ride all right
so dotnet was open-source you may have
heard we open-source dotnet in 2001 you
know that we've actually you know that's
a real thing this is not like fake news
it's real we open sourced it we just did
a really bad job of it
it wasn't open source it was source
opened it was like we zipped it up we
pulled out all the good stuff and we
said the rest of it is left as an
exercise to the reader we took out the
jitter and the garbage collector and
basically anything interesting or
patentable or anything we could charge
money for and we made this zip file and
we called it wrote her our OTO R and we
thought that we would put that out
another community except some things
didn't exist at the time what didn't
exist yet
github social media beyond I don't know
mailing lists and emailing diff files
and patch files real social media also
the organizational willpower to do good
was failing at the time so we continued
to try to open-source things and we
really got it right when we released
what I like to call dotnet on nails
which was in no way a reaction to Ruby
on Rails handing our asses to us totally
unrelated that we would release an MVC
framework when the rise of another MVC
framework was happening
that's totally by the way what we did we
needed an answer to Rails no seriously
though this was open source and it was
open source in order to try to fool the
lawyers into saying yes by default
because they would say no to basically
anything we would ask for so we just
slowly move the line a little bit like
there was a rule that said you could
release a sample without talking to a
lawyer if it was more than a
it was less than 100 lines but like
hello world and c-sharp is like 98 line
so you couldn't really release a useful
sample if you especially if you put all
of your curly braces on a different line
so we would just do everything on one
long line one long linked statement and
that was the sample and we couldn't
change that rule but we could change the
number of lines so we changed it to a
thousand lines and we would just slowly
ask forgiveness because asking
permission was really hard and now we're
in a really cool situation where
Microsoft is doing everything opened by
default we actually have meetings about
whether or not we should not open-source
something and basically everything's
been open-source so fast forward and now
everything's open-source all the way
down to the metal to the compiler and
I'm going to show you a bunch of stuff
that we've been doing but also much of
the community's been doing I've got some
exciting things that you would not
expect to be able to do in dotnet that
make me very happy now right now about
60% of the contributions are coming from
outside of Microsoft Google and Samsung
or huge contributors to dotnet so more
people are working on dotnet outside
Microsoft and are inside which is a good
thing here's a cool map that marketing
gave me with some blobs
that's 2015 blobs that's 2016 blobs 2018
is really exciting because we finally
obliterated New Zealand which was which
is a personal goal of mine and this
shows that we have dotnet contributions
from everywhere including a boat there's
a person on a boat right there they're
either on a boat or they're at zero
comma zero but either way I don't mind
because they they offered a good
contribution and we merged it so it
doesn't really matter now Microsoft
named this thing dotnet which I always
thought was a little bit odd audacious
like we just co-opted an entire
top-level domain like completely
obliterating my whole org strategy that
I was trying to do as a person but who
would have the audacity to do something
to name something dotnet or to like name
something just a simple noun to make an
editor and call it code and think that
that was okay and still we did it and I
think that's that's awesome
but dotnet in the past has been a thing
that we kind of afraid of it's a thing
that
is installed on windows and if it's not
installed on windows the only reason
that you really would install it would
be because you want to run paint.net
alright so I gotta run paint oh shoot I
got installed on that and then I gotta
get paint on it well what happens with
dotnet right now because it slowed down
dotnet four four five four six four
seven four seven point one point two
point one point eight point six
September refresh is it's a fundamental
part of windows.net has become an engine
of Windows and what happens is someone
will go and write some code in like
dotnet 4.0 and it'll work great let's
say this gentleman writes an app and
it's amazing and he puts it on my is
it's like an expense reporting app and
it's stable and he likes it and it works
and then this young lady comes to work
at the company and she does dotnet for
point eight point two because it uses
c-sharp eight and she wants to use the
new hotness and she's excited about this
great new world net
she writes an app it works great on her
machine and then she goes over to to IT
and says can I install four point eight
point two on the server and he's like
why not well because I don't want to
piss it off like I don't want to anger
the thing like there's a reboot and it
might not work and then she quits her
job and anger becomes a node developer
and then rely and falls into a pit of
node modules and never gets out and it's
a whole thing but that's another talk
the point is we didn't set either of you
up for success because you want a stable
reliable thing that you don't have to
update every twenty minutes with patches
that is reliable and you want the latest
stuff you want to be able to do new
language features and see innovation so
you got a balance these two dot Nets
Nets plural all the while someone is
creating another dotnet mono mono is a
cleanroom re-implementation of dotnet
cleanroom reimplementation that means
that they wrote another dotnet without
looking at the source because they were
afraid of patents because we were doing
all kinds of crazy patent stuff we
shouldn't even do it and they were like
well we'll make a dotnet that's shaped
like dotnet it look
like dotnet it quacks like dotnet but we
won't read the source and what they
would do is they'd say all right let's
look at the shape of a string what does
a string have it's got cysteine you know
that dock contains and dot length and
dot compared to it's at all stringy
stuff and if I said hey you go write me
a string don't look at the source here's
the interface you would do that
and your string would be different than
my string they'd probably use the same
techniques but if the tests passed we'd
have to complete implementations of
string that'd be cool right and and then
we bought them and then now they became
xamarin and they have a bunch of stuff
though that the other dot nets don't
have like these are three different nets
one on Windows one that is dotnet core
which runs on Linux or a dozen different
Linux's and then you've got mono which
enables things like iOS and Android and
that's really interesting but it isn't a
bad thing it isn't like oh man we've got
three nets this sucks
there's stuff happening in mono like
ahead of time compilation there's stuff
happening around about interpretation
and being able to interpret il or
c-sharp c-sharp that compiles to i/o and
then there's a jitter that's being
worked on on the.net framework side like
64 bit nationally parallel jitters on
modern processors so if 3 dot nets that
are all innovating in cool ways what we
really need is to combine all of that
work and make all the dot nets better
but also justify the existence of why
there would need to be 3 now it's worth
pointing out that the dotnet framework
in dotnet core compiled with Visual
Studio and they think about Visual
Studio and C and C++ in an idiomatically
Visual Studio place they're not super
portable they're pretty affordable
doesn't course quite portable it
compiles well on Linux people have
compiled it for armed people to compile
it for different processors but mono is
is really well thought of as a as a
piece of portable C code it's a piece of
code where you can get clone apt-get
build essentials configure and make it's
extraordinarily clean you can work with
mono on a Nintendo Wii it powers the
unity you can make games for a switch
there's value in that clean
portable c-code donek or a huge amount
of perf work has been done to make that
as fast as possible and we're actually
bumping up against the laws of physics
itself as we saturate gigabit pipes and
ten gigabit pipes with seven eight
million requests a second so you go and
look at the tech and power benchmarks
there's about 10 or 11 frameworks that
are all clustered at the top and they
all asymptotically approach 8 million
requests a second because that's just
simply how many bytes you can get into a
pipe so there's a lot of fun happening
in the benchmarking space as we do a
little bit of a thumb war not a
competition but a coopertition with all
the different frameworks to see how we
can you know do micro benchmarks now a
micro benchmark isn't a good enough
reason to use one framework or over
another but it's super-fun and it also
shows that the turf work that we're
doing in dotnet core is really cool
because it's about 10 to 11 times faster
than node in real tight loops which is
cool ok that's the end of the slides
let's go into the the the PowerShell
prompt here and let's go out to the
desktop and we'll make a folder here and
there's nothing in this folder because I
didn't go into that folder there's
nothing in this folder yeah cool I'm
gonna go back and forth between too big
and too small because because reasons
okay now if I say we're right so if you
would all just look away here we have
that situation where because here's the
thing
I typed like a hundred words a minute
but like 90 or backspace'
and you know how you're just like typing
as fast as your brain can type and then
your coworker is like looking over you
look beat and then suddenly your hands
are all covered in like novocaine like
you just went to the dentist and you're
trying to type that's me so if you would
all just look avert your eyes because I
don't even know what I was trying to
type there and I've only had two
breakfasts today so I don't know what's
happening
might I wear net you can see the dotnet
is in C program files dotnet nxn exe
that's not c : windows that's not
something to be afraid of and if I
actually go down into Program Files
dotnet and poke around in there I've got
a bunch of dotnet a bunch of dot nets
down in there they're all side by side
and I can pin dot nets to different
folders that means that if I type dot
net - - version here I might get one
version but if I go into another folder
and I type dot net - - version I might
get another so I can rest assured that
I'll get the version that I expect
especially if I hand it out to someone
so I can pin that down it's all built in
which is cool even though it's all
coming from that same location okay now
I'm gonna do things at the command line
because I'm nondenominational when it
comes to IDE s you should use whatever
IDE makes you happy you should use you
know project writer from JetBrains your
visual studio code or Visual Studio or
the city or the Mac or Emacs or them and
if you use vim on Windows Windows 10
reboots faster than ever so exiting them
is way easier you just reboot you can be
back and working in just like a minute
it's really great I'm gonna say dotnet
new console and we're gonna call it the
London con and we'll go into that folder
and I'll say London con will say dotnet
run one one thousand two one thousand
three one thousand Microsoft sucks
that's basically the kind of the process
is you download dotnet and then you
declare that we sucked because that took
three seconds and then you can
to go or node or Python or whatever yeah
that sucks but if we go see every time
sometimes I type the wrong thing
multiple times like for awhile I was
typing Dockett instead of docker so I
just made a batch file called docket dot
bat that was just you gotta you know
smooth the speed bumps um so if I say
dotnet build and we can see that there
is a dotnet DLL right there
and if I say dotnet that DLL so you know
it's fast because run implies a restore
of the packages and a build and then a
run so there is a lot of speed there and
I can prove it by doing a formal
benchmark alright so then I can move
that to the cloud and I've got like
cloud and neighbor and containerized
kubernetes hello world in the cloud
that's scale all right no the cool part
though is that that's super fast but
that DLL is sitting right there let's
open that up let's go out to the
developer command prompt and let's type
ill dazzle which is the name of my
mixtape and also a tool that is built
into dotnet this is a pretty fancy new
UI windows 11 preview of the high
quality Metro interface that the kids
are using look at those icons
somebody painted that like I don't know
if that person is dead or what's gonna
and I can look in here and we see the
the intermediate language so we just
compiled c-sharp to the intermediate
language C sharp is is apples and
running it is apple juice this is AB the
sauce what's great about apple sauce and
what's a little bit weird about it is F
sharp is oranges but it compiles to
apple sauce same thing with VB and all
the other languages right the fruit that
they end up ending up being is this
pre-shoot apple sauce and if we look at
that we can read this I'm sure we've all
been trained to read il from birthright
line one not don't know what that does
like to learn stir and then call so we
load a string into the stack and we say
call system console dot write line who
does the actual writing of the string to
the screen the operating system right
there's nothing there about the
implementation assistance of counsel cuz
that's coming from a library what's
interesting about that is that we all
sometimes forget what's underneath
what's one layer down in the call stack
we get so used to working on what we
think is the metal at the young people
today I think the metal is f12 tools in
chrome I'm working on the metal
low-level code yeah right in a virtual
machine inside of a larger process
inside of fifteen chrome processes on
top of Windows which is running in a
virtual machine on and a boon to machine
that it and it's just Turtles all the
way down this is dotnet metal and we
fool ourselves sometimes thinking that
that's low-level but ultimately it's
going to call Windows or Linux or Mac
for that console dot write line and
that's really important to remember when
we think about portability now I made
this in dotnet core but what if I did
this and I opened up mono and picked a
reasonable font
and then thought again and picked a
reasonable font size and then typed mono
and that yellow this simple
demonstration this idea that an an
executable or in this case a DLL with an
entry point can be run on dotnet core or
on windows.net
or on mono is a testament to the power
of that standard that Ekman standard
that i that standard of this apple sauce
that we're all speaking mono doesn't
know that that's from dotnet core Amano
doesn't really care so that's super
interesting and that makes me wonder
like how truly portable is that stuff
well it's portable until it hits some
low-level syscall system call or C code
some win32 or Linux shared object or
some thing that's platform specific
right if I wrote some code and I said
hello world this and whole world that
motor bunch of for loops and did some
HTTP calls and then said open the
registry it would all work until the
open the registry part if the registry
didn't exist on that platform and then I
can go and think about how I want to
write my code and make it more portable
now if I go over here it's Lunden con
I'll go back up and I want to make I
want to say dotnet new now I've been
saying class live and I said that and
Damien Edwards and David Fowler recoiled
in horror I don't have a gif of it but
it was a lot like and there was an
implied mmm-hmm
do you do you say class Lib is it a Lib
do you get books at the library is this
going to be the whole gif gif thing
again because what's happening is now a
thousand people have just said no it's
it's Lib right no it's not it's live
it's library
so I hope I hope you're not offended
keep in mind that the David Fowler is
also one of the people who tried to make
new get packages nut kegs
so his decisions are not considered to
be valid
so I'll go down here to this this file
that we will not speak its name someone
remember this here we'll say greetings
public static string hello and then
we'll say return hello NDC Hell NDC yeah
that's that's probably better all right
and now if I was really trying to be
like it like a like a gate keeper which
is a bad thing I would probably say copy
con food CS and then I'd do it all at
the command line like this because you
only get one chance if you do it like
this and then you go like this and then
you say control Z and it copies and then
people people wonder where what a con is
and where we're copying from it and what
just happened this is text editors for
like Yolo people just you have its right
only one line at a time
Khan is actually the console alright so
let's go here and I'm going to go back
up to that London con and I'm gonna do
the command line equivalent of
right-click references add project
because I want the console to reference
the library cool
so dotnet dot dot next newt dotnet add
reference dot dot London Lib star dot C
is proj so I've added a reference to
that and I can open up that that CS proj
file I don't I don't know what I'm doing
and you can see that it's added that
reference so there's XML there but
you're gonna vert your eyes and just
pretend it's not alright because I know
that the kids are not doing angle
brackets now because curly braces and
mustaches are way cooler but tonight
just as I learned curly braces now it's
Gamal which is just white space and I've
actually had like full systems and
production and kubernetes go down
because of a misplaced tab
but it's still way better right everyone
agrees it's way better it's not like we
needed validation or maybe a schema or
anything like that I think I'm not
saying soap was a good thing but I'm
just saying I built some stuff and still
running on soap that's all I'm saying
but enjoy your enjoy your whitespace now
you can use yellow that's fine I'll just
think mean things about you
London Lib and then what did we call it
we said bar equals was a greeting dot
hello okay I'm using notepad - it's one
better than notepad check it out okay
and then I will say dotnet run okay I
blame you all for that
because one of you it's greetings thank
you for helping people who thought that
they were going to help me but they
didn't want to speak up because they're
English I'm picking on the English
because this guy at work who does this
impression of Hugh Grant entering a room
that he shouldn't have all it is is
basically oh sorry oh I shouldn't be
here
and I think that's all I can think about
so I feel like someone wanted to help me
oh it's like all right
part of me choose me so if you see a
mistake please help me is this called
mob programming and I will very likely
have a misplaced million dollar
semicolon at some point I'd really use
your help okay so at this point here
I've only got these two things I could
certainly go and make a solution and I
could go and add these projects to the
solution I could say add London Kahn and
I could go and add London live gonna
take me a while to retrain myself so now
I've added those to the solution file I
could say dotnet build and I could build
all those things so I'm doing all of
this at the command line because when
you go into Visual Studio gives you a
code or writer or whatever these things
are what's happening this is what
happens when you learn to drive a
stick-shift
and then you move to an automatic shift
car it's just nice to know what's
happening underneath so now I could go
and say dotnet new razor London Web
dotnet run like I said thank you too
late though try harder next time sort of
could have helped could have used your
help a second ago thank you though for
yelling that was perfect I need that and
then because I'm in Dawson I don't have
control are and I'm not there clever
okay and then we'll go and we'll say
code dot will open up visual studio code
and we'll take a look at one of these
pages this is a nice little web thing
we're making here and we'll say using
London line Lib look I forget if these
are needed or not I don't know
some of those some of those may be
needed I'm not sure
greetings dot hello I thought they
needed they are needed
what about colons are those allowed I
don't know is that right you don't know
you're thinking is gonna break you think
it's good you think it's bad okay if it
breaks that's on you
it doesn't break then I will raise my
fist to triumphantly it's not gonna work
there's no way it worked
you'll see now you said it didn't work
before so you know there's a it's not
working for other reasons though it's
what I think why is it bad
the using isn't needed
well the semicolon is not needed but it
actually didn't work right so there's
other reasons that this is bad like not
working is also part of it what in the
French hell out there this happened
yesterday where's Damian it had David
how did you figure this out no it's not
that
so I'm on a daily build of a daily build
of a fork of a friend's cousins build of
the dotnet core 3 and what we're seeing
is we switched everything to http by
default and we're having trouble with
the switchover so if you have like the
wrong port and your HTTP you go on this
port and things freak out and kestrel
needs to basically upgrade everyone to
here so that worked thank you though
hello in DC so now I've you know that's
don't I don't want your pity applause
it's like the the hate of the happy
parent it's so cute to just watch you
know it's like watching a three-legged
dog you know you know he he's gonna get
where he's going but it's just sad to
watch watching Scott do live coding is
just it's adorable right you know he's
just not a good ballet dancer but he
loves the sport so much I'm just gonna
use it a back over here and continue to
fail on stage here what's significant
about this is the fact that if we go up
to London Lib and we look at that CS
proj what the best part is that you
because I'm so bad at programming that
you you don't know if it's a joke or not
right it gives me plausible deniability
I just put in a couple of extra
semicolons and some curly braces and
then then you help me and then you feel
good about yourself and then you don't
know I could be the best programmer ever
I could have been coasting on charm for
twenty five years and you have no could
be put a little both we don't know right
now you're all wondering what the
mystery is
here is the London live London lib
it's a dotnet standard library that's
significant notice it doesn't say dotnet
core doesn't seem mono it doesn't say a
lot of framework is it's on its standard
it's that agreement it's an agreement of
these are the api's that everybody will
be able to do its console dot write line
its string dot contains its all of those
different things that one would want to
do and if you make your own dotnet if
you fork dotnet and build it for a
processor that we haven't seen you need
to make that implementation a dotnet
standard implementation barring a few
things that you might want to throw and
say well you know not implemented like
if it doesn't have a screen then you
might not do bitmaps or whatever right
it doesn't have a file system then you
have a problem if it doesn't do things
in a certain way then don't implement
those pieces and throw not implemented
but for the most part you want to have
things be dotnet standard okay that
dotnet standard thing is so important
because it allows us to do crazy stuff
now remember how we compiled c-sharp
2il the IL was the applesauce
and then we ran it we ran it in mono we
ran it and da ting that we ran it anyway
right on the web at the command line
what other apple sauce style
technologies are currently available
well it turns out that M scripting and
scripting and script in freaking how to
pronounce it
you can take a C application and then
compile it to the apple sauce of the web
which is web assembly right it's this
pre-chewed version of java script that
is easily digestible for babies and
browsers and I can take that C app and I
can run it in the browser
right so I'll just fire up a little what
does that dotnet that was kind of cool
actually we should name it that das ness
that's how it's pronounced I'm gonna say
dotnet serve which is a tiny little
global tool that you can use if you need
a web server just like on the fly it's
like hey give me a web server and then I
will go and say localhost 8080 and
that's the little dotnet web server
that's sitting right there and I'll
visit this hello dat HTML and that's the
C app running inside of this in the
context of web simply so if I can
compile C code in such a way then what's
we're some really convenient portable C
code that one could go and do some
damage with mono so if you compiled mono
to webassembly what kind of damage could
you potentially do you may have had the
the joy and the pleasure to see some of
the work that Steve Sanderson genius
programmer has been working on and he
gave a talk yesterday and will say
dotnet New London blaze da net new blaze
or blaze or go down into here and then I
will say
add a reference go open up code again
and I think we'll be in here
we'll do a little of this little HTML a
little at little greetings a little
hello all right let's see dotnet run I'm
wondering if I've left something on
another port thinking about it thinking
about it
something's happening then I'm going to
open up competitive browser and then I'm
going to look at competitive browser and
comment on the fact that I'm using Bing
as my homepage I'm using this cool new
feature it's a Bing extension it's good
to Chrome extension called Bing new tab
it's really cool because when you hit
ctrl T you get to see Bing but then if
you search for stuff it uses Google so
that gives you the benefit of being and
also the ability to find things on on
the Internet
so there's that same exact dotnet
standard DLL showing up in this web app
okay so that's cool so I'm going to hit
f12 and then I will casually point out
to some people who may not know that if
you hit f12 in chrome and you right
click on the refresh button it gives you
extra menu items that weren't there
otherwise what's cool about little tips
like that if you throw those into your
talks is every once in a while
someone will go that happened yesterday
at a talk and I was giving it was like
like nobody cared and you're all very
quiet and polite and nobody wanted to
leave and I was doing ok and then I did
that tip and the person went hmm it was
kind of a Grover Sesame Street Yoda kind
of a thing mmm and that told me that
that person had derived value from the
talk nothing I had said up to that point
was useful
I was literally compiling mono into web
assembly and running it in a browser and
talking about nested virtual machines
running in a compatible and open-source
way but it was that right-click that
elicited and so if you feel the need to
utter like Yoda that would be just very
it makes me feel good about my job all
right now I'm gonna go and hit refresh
and I'm going to point to this dares
mono that's cool
mono Azzam and look look look look look
look look
did we compile the London Lib to wasm
they would see the one saw that step we
did not know he just shipped it the
exact same one that I made we shipped
all the way to the browser and it ran in
here thereby making the Internet itself
dotnet standard compliant seriously you
think I'm joking no mmm so that's
interesting that brings the idea of code
reuse real code reuse to another level
like if you've got a really awesome
tested something the potential for code
reviews is really huge what other kind
of damage
I mean productivity could one it could
one potentially do with that what if I
had some like a windows forms
application because people still make
those in fact it's one of the number-one
projects that people are making is
windows forms it's like the most common
thing that people do because it's the
fastest way to get a button on a page
right it's true that that was the value
right there no it really is it's just
buttons buttons buttons right like I
could just throw them onto the page you
know if we add it like a physics thing
that would like give them a little bit
of oomph and they'd have momentum it
would be really cool so this is a
Windows forms memory game like a kids
matching game and then us was that the
symbol of chile's apparently they're
gonna sue us and I'm not good at these
games this is Windows forms now Windows
forms typically needs net the.net full
framework the one that we're afraid to
install right and you don't want to go
and say well this customer has 4.6 and
everything works but in order to run my
app I need 4.7 so we took dotnet core 3
and did a brain transplant and put
dotnet core underneath these legacy but
no longer legacy applications so that I
can just X copy deploy and give you a
folder with your own personal private
version of.net even with bug fixes
because WinForms and WPF are both open
source with take-backs
and then you might say well I don't want
a two gig folder in order to run my
matching game
well the matching game only needs
certain parts right only needs certain
functions remember how I talked about
the different Nets they have different
innovations there's some cool
innovations that's happening in the mono
side was called tree trimming what if
you took your application and you hung
it with all the dependencies down to the
function level then you shook it and the
leaves of the functions that you don't
use fell off and you use one function in
system XML or one function and system
dot string the other ones just aren't
needed because they're not part of the
hot path and they fall away and you can
get dotnet down to sixty Meg's thirty
Meg's little tiny dot Nets but that's
not that interesting
this WinForms application that's running
on dotnet three uses logic that is
written in a dotnet standard DLL so what
if what if I could go over here and run
this application
wondering again if I've left something
on port 5,000
what is that okay
that's that WinForms app running in the
browser okay
is it really or is it all lies Microsoft
with the dollar sign no that is the
logic part about 85 to 90 percent code
reuse with the part that painted having
been simply swapped out for divs because
before the logic stuff was factored out
right it's just talking to those
controls that have control hierarchy and
wind forms it can just as easily talk to
a control hierarchy here now I'm not
promising 99% code reuse but I am trying
to show you what is possible that's real
and that's cool now I'm not saying that
all of your incredibly well factored
legacy wind forms apps are gonna
I'm what I am saying is both of you that
have well factored WinForms apps have a
bright future ahead of you
but that but that's not all what else
could we do potentially with a that
London Lib what else could we do that
would be causing some damage I brought
this device with me let me see if I can
bring up the camera and show you this
there's a bunch of cables and a bunch of
stuff look it's seeing it's seeing my
face and then also secondarily
identifying my face here in the other
face you got a somebody tweet that
because that's too cool
no pressure my face hurts all right
thank you what I brought was this I was
stopped at the border and that's fine
[Laughter]
there were there were discussions there
was a conversation
he was awkward but then I booted up
raspberry-pi on a tiny screen and told
them it was made in London or close
enough Frank this has got all kinds of
widgets and cool fun stuff and it's
actually powered by this this petite
little battery that I use to keep my
iPhone running for more than an hour so
I'm running this entire box off of this
now what I've done I'm gonna put that
down here is I have made a new
application called this this is using
the new system dot devices dot GPIO
general purpose i/o that is now built
into dotnet 3 we just shipped it in
preview 2 so I can actually write
c-sharp code here to talk to the devices
in this case the Raspberry Pi is wired
up to an LCD display yeah that's cool
then I could shush over to that machine
I'm trying to make that a thing
we're shushing into machines now do you
think we can eight to have it you know
you're not excited about that I just
want you to throw it out casually at
work yeah could you just shush into that
that machine over there no yeah
try it out but say it casually you don't
want to throw it down their throats you
want them to feel like it's a thing that
they didn't know about but all these
years
people have been rushing into computers
and you'd been doing they've been saying
it wrong
you follow why that's important please
try to make that happen only for people
who haven't actually been to this to
this talk we want to just shame the
people who are at at work right now who
didn't come to NBC those other people
suck so I can go and run that and then
because I can't can I do a camera to the
camera again do this mm-hmm and that's
cool but then I thought to myself that
was too hard that was a lot of shushing
and what I really want to do is I want
to leave things like be able to write
the code on Windows set a breakpoint on
Windows build it here press f5 have it
automatically publish a copy of dotnet
via SCP or secure copy over to the PI
then attach to remote instance of an arm
build of the visual studio debugger and
drop into a breakpoint pause for effect
right there so now I am cross debugging
between this x64 machine in this arm
machine with dotnet core 3 and Visual
Studio code and what's interesting about
this is that I haven't paid Microsoft
anything that's cool it's open source
all the way down to the metal I can even
see local variables step over and all
that stuff ok but since that didn't
cause you to applaud and I don't want
your pity so don't start now
I thought to myself that's fun that will
make my IOT you know projects more cool
and you know I don't have to learn other
languages because I'm a c-sharp elitist
and but this is a lot to say hello world
this is a micro computer this is running
raspbian a full in the instance of Linux
if I ran top you'd see like 19 things
running
there's cron jobs it's a little overkill
for 4 for production but at the same
time you see that I even had to do the
build here like I could build it on the
Raspberry Pi but it might take a long
time when I want to wait 10 minutes what
is something that is smaller than a
micro computer well something that is
smaller is a microcontroller but that
would be insane because you can't run
dotnet and jitters and all the stuff
that is the dotnet of it all on
something that is like his size of a tic
tac TIF Tic Tacs here write a little
like a tic tac box maybe down an actual
Tic Tac because then you can actually
swallow dotnet and that'd be like the
whole thing like a tic tac box ok so
what I did is I talked to our friends at
wilderness labs wilderness labs is doing
a Kickstarter and what they've done it's
pretty bananas
let me bring a camera up over here and
then I'm gonna do a handheld in a second
wilderness labs gave me one of four
pre-production meadow devices this is a
alpha of an alpha they made four of
these they're gonna do they've had a
successful Kickstarter you can buy these
but a wilderness lab Co sign up for
their mailing list I have no
relationship with the company other than
they loaned me this ok but this is the
power of gotta net this is the
development board the actual board will
be like well I'm not trying to flip off
an entire crowd but let's just say it's
middle finger sized right these bits
will go then I've taken the same LCD and
wired it up now I'm not I took
electrical engineering but I'm also
color blind so these are all different
but only to me I'm told that wiring
diagrams are easier when it's got
multiple colors so I put a splash of
blue here okay so this device right here
is not a not a microcomputer it doesn't
run a full operating system as a micro
operating system it runs nut X and you
TT X an open source operating system
with like a one megabyte footprint and I
can't like plug it in and have it look
like a disk so in fact I have to flash
the firmware of the entire thing with
this device an ST link so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to switch over to this
Macintosh here that I've set up for this
reason I'm also gonna grab my power off
of this and plug it in over here now in
the future I'm told by the friends at
meadow that this will be an f5 plug it
in Auto you know automatically kind of
like work with Visual Studio but again
as an alpha you know it is what it is
and I think it's pretty impressive so
let's plug into our Mac and let's bring
that up on the big screen okay there's a
Mac looking Mac ish let me go into
Visual Studio right here so this is
Visual Studio for Mac and what I'm doing
here is making a dotnet DLL that uses
dotnet standard dll's we're literally
talking about a dotnet standard
microcontroller platform how would that
be possible you think about all the
overhead of jitters and stuff like that
remember I said before they are the
beginning of the talk how exciting it
was that we have multiple nets and the
different pieces of innovation that are
now coming together because all the dot
nets are under one roof you've got cool
stuff happening in the just-in-time or
jitter just-in-time compilation you have
cool stuff happening the ahead of time
compilation to compile dotnet all the
way down to apple juice
and then you have cool things happening
in the interpretation space if you take
a look at a really great application on
the iPad called continuous codes
continuous dot codes
it is Visual Studio for the iPad
effectively it's an IDE for typing in
the iPad but of course iPads and iOS
don't allow and and arbitrary
running of code what they did is Frank
who wrote it took the Roslyn interpreter
and runs the interpreter on the iPad so
with a microcontroller what you could do
is get some of it interpret some of it
ahead of time compile some of it and
howl of all of those contexts flow
between and you get best-in-class
performance and battery life in the
order of weeks as opposed to in the
order of hours or something like a
Raspberry Pi so here I'm going to do
things like talk to the digital port
talk to the LCD and toggle some LEDs and
say hello NDC now today in order to do
that it's a little bit more complicated
I just got to run out to the terminal
here but again this will be easy in the
future I'm told and I'm gonna go and say
run st util so I've just fired up gdb a
good new debugger listening on port 42
42 and then over here I'm going to run
it and then say remote target 42 42 and
then we are now flashing the firmware
through the dots we're flashing the
firmware and the microcontroller will
effectively boot into dotnet okay now in
order to show that to you I'm gonna do
this clever hack that my buddy backstage
suggested which is to go into my phone
and I'm gonna put the phone on the HDMI
okay pop that up there sir
okay so we're thinking looking at dots
things are flashing screens are
screening these wires are gray which was
interesting so I brought them all the
way here hopefully one of the wires did
not move or somebody moved it as a goof
okay it's resetting and now it's going
to boot into Emma's core Lib
[Applause]
I want to say big thanks to Brian
Costanza and our friends at wilderness
labs this is called the meadow meadow
device it is right now where he's
working on his getting his kick starter
out let's go ahead and switch over to
the Windows machine he's working on
getting his kick starter out and then
you'll be able to get those soon now
what's interesting about all of this and
why I think it is a great piece of
punctuation for Microsoft's open-source
journey go ahead and heat up the Windows
machine there sir in the back is this
idea that that windows forms developer
that person that's been writing C sharp
or VB for 10 years and may be thinking
yeah you know I did this III see all the
new stuff happening but it's not for me
I'm saying it is for you it is
absolutely for you and what's exciting
about that is it's for you because you
know C sharp you know the language you
know the base class library which is
effectively the dotnet standard system
got string system dot file all the
things you do every day in WinForms or
in web forms or an MVC you just became a
cloud developer container developer
kubernetes developer an iPhone developer
an Android developer a Raspberry Pi or
even microcontroller developer that's
really exciting to me now I believe in
people being polyglots so certainly
having this support in VB and F sharp
and C sharp and other languages is super
interesting and that's what makes that
intermediate language so interesting and
the idea that if I produce a dotnet
standard DLL that is smart about when it
touches the metal and which parts of the
metal it is judicious about for example
you saw me talking to system dot device
GPIO there isn't that on Windows unless
you're running that exact same sample on
Windows IOT core and then it would work
that nice so you have those drivers that
do the appropriate call down to the the
metal so that is my talk that's some of
the cool stuff that's being worked on
right now at Microsoft outside Microsoft
there's also things like hashed layer H
ast layer which is compiling dotnet to
FPGA chips there's really cool
stuff that's happening and none of it
would have been possible if we hadn't
just opened it all up all the way down
to the metal so thank you very much for
spending time with me this morning and I
hope you have a wonderful NDC and you
can check me out also at 2 o'clock where
I'm going to be talking about my open
source artificial pancreas I'm a type 1
diabetic and I've got IOT devices
plugged into me and I'm going to talk
about how we solve diabetes problems
with open source and open source
hardware thank you very much
[Applause]